good morning everybody today is our
first day in Japan super excited
actually I'm not sure if it's really
settled in yet but we are getting ready
to grub because as we all know when you
travel is always about the food if you
travel that you don't want to eat the
food stay at your [ __ ] house decide
to explore Tokyo for me personally Tokyo
is not the place that I want to go see
the most it's probably Osaka and Kyoto
because I heard there's a lot of culture
there a lot of history the temple which
is where I personally want to go so
we're waiting for a Joe Cristina and
just to get ready then we're going to
bounce out see a lot of Japanese people
shake people's hands
probably not I'm hoping that somebody
groped me on a train I'm just like a
[ __ ] in the palm of their hands
so what is the plan job so we are gonna
I have no idea what's going on but we're
gonna walk to the train station since
we've never done this before I've been
here once but I was with Japanese
speakers that knew everything so I just
walked around and I just went and this
time I guess we're just gonna go to the
station and ask them hey how do you get
there because we got to meet up with
everybody perfect dude I'm so hype dude
I'm ready to get groped by somebody I
want some you I want somebody to jiggle
my balls right now
I'm waiting if you feel somebody grope
you switch places so you just grab my
ass real quick I'm hoping somebody grabs
my butthole I think we're waiting for
that [ __ ]
so I'm barely in Japan is etiquette not
to really talk that loud in the train
that's why I'm whispering into my camera
like a voyeur the Stone Age people walk
in this country is absolutely insane
everybody is flooding there I feel like
I'm a slow [ __ ]
okay so Hachi is a story of a very loyal
dog so hot she can walk with her owner
every day and every day that's went on
up until the point of his death when he
died she would just come to the station
and sit and wait the whole day and then
everybody started noticing and you know
this dog is just sitting here waiting
every single day and they all used to
help take care of it all that stuff
until the point of Hodge goes dead so
it's like a awesome story about how much
the dog loved the owner a [ __ ] dog
wouldn't do that dude
I just gave my dog to my parents to take
over for two weeks she [ __ ] left
without even looking at me and she's
just like [ __ ] you somehow she lifts up
her little pod said [ __ ] out of here
non-stop even internationally than our
fans of JK films region is so famous you
popular five seconds later thanks very
she ate it we are reunited did you buy
anything you're so [ __ ] embarrassing
whatever we go she makes a fool of
herself look at her right now
nobody isn't watching as she's still
dancing absolute shame where's she going
she's sitting around today I'm saying
that saying you're beautiful you are the
cutest thing I've ever seen in my life
oh my god oh my god there's your
butthole hair mesh on top of your head
your [ __ ] creature go home this is
the craziest thing Yoshino you're back
in the States does not look like this at
all
this is ridiculous Yoshino you're back
in the states if you guys had it it's
like instant diarrhea it's like the
greasiest meat you could ever get with
some shitty ass rice but is one of those
quick bites that you always get to eat
if you want like quick Japanese beef
that is a completely different thing
we got to his house because the Airbnb
owner said that okay the doors are open
you guys just walking in so focuses
house buying you there's ten of us l
allowed luggages dragging down the
street so we will whole neighborhood we
coulda had half Azura have our shoes off
Sean comes upstairs and sees a dude like
through the crack of a door watching TV
with earphones on so he didn't even hear
us he's like oh I hope he gets our house
we put her she's back on child so I see
and then leave hello store and the guy
didn't even know our house was three
doors down
you're the crazy if that was LA he would
have been butt raped in a second well we
would have been shot I would have tied
him down and stuck my penis in his ear
right you guys have to realize how small
the space is I have to duck every step
so I think the the interesting thing
about Japan is Japan is always about
service and then the weirdest way
possible service is done this way you
see what that is basically it's like a
service bar world where women go to get
pampered by certain types of men so
there's like the doctor type there's a
sweet time baby I kind of want to go in
myself to see if they'll pepper a man
so big-ass head set a big head socked
you in the back of your head right now
you have the perfect back head soccer
bonus we just made it right now miss you
so much design check this out is deep
fried with a shiso leaf I'm on the air
like a few more in love leave fried pork
it's like I don't cut see this is the
fried salmon and she's you know how
typically people always say that you're
not supposed to mix cheese really
seafood why like culinary people always
say that you never mix seafood and
cheese but 80 people always do it all
the time just nice and crispy it's like
this is chance to really create ease our
next fried dish this is an asparagus
dish apparently the way we eat this
you're not going to add anything else to
it it's already sauce a season for you
so I guess it would be blasphemy if you
added a sauce to it so I'm not going to
do it well there's a bit of I'm moving
here I totally drop then I made a
favorite I already had a beer in terms
with my steak is doing that's a
grapefruit good good
like a tit and we have another place to
go I don't you realize I don't drink
you're clean I understand
higher pressure good a few drinks later
I gotta go down because I probably can
look down now cuz I'm a little drunk
it's not making me sweaty at all
oh I'm dry it doesn't matter okay
scaring me a little movie